Станіслава та її колеги-активісти хочуть бути помітними.
Навіть попри те, що не всі будуть раді їх бачити.
Поки ми розмовляємо, Станіслава, яка допомагає організовувати харківський прайд,
отримує новини про протест проти ЛГБТ в іншому районі міста.
Така ворожість для неї не нова.
У нас демократична країна, тому я не бачу нічого поганого,
щоб люди висловлювали свою думку в такий спосіб.
Це набагато краще, ніж переслідування, погрози і побиття людей,
що також часто трапляється після прайду.
Активістів більше хвилюють російські ракетні атаки.
Це одна з причин, чому прийшло небагато людей.
Інша причина - багато хто покинув місто.
Але також - дехто з них воює з росіянами.
Вирізані силуети представляють тих, кого немає.
Але вони були тут недовго.
Не минуло й двох годин, а деякі з вирізаних силуетів вже відсутні.
Але вони неподалік, як ви бачите тут.
Я можу витягти один з них для вас.
Тут  написано: "Це могла б бути Марічка, але вона евакуює поранених на фронті".
Ті, хто це зробив, і досі тут. І, здається, не соромляться камери.
Зараз, я вважаю, взагалі не той час, щоб агітувати от таке.
Я ж кажу, було б логічніше, щоб замість отаких постерів,
таких чоловічків райдужних, поставили б монумент і встановили фото хлопців,
які віддали життя за Харків, за Україну в цілому.
Більшість символічних фігур не дочекається одинадцятої вечора,
коли настає комендантська година. Їх забрали, знищили або зіпсували.
Українське законодавство досі визнає лише шлюб між чоловіком і жінкою.
Але опитування показують, що більш ніж половина українців
підтримують одностатеві шлюби, близько чверті виступають проти.
Це є інтимні речі.
Яка б там культура не була, якої б орієнтації ви б не були,
це не має значення для того, щоб це все на люди (виносити)…
Вони ж нікого не ображають цим.
Кожен має право кохати того, кого він хоче кохати.
Тим часом за більш ніж півтори тисячі кілометрів від Харкова
українські ЛГБТ-активісти долучилися до прайду,
що пройшов цього літа вулицями Берліна.
У традиційному 45-му прайді на вулицях німецької столиці
взяли участь понад пів мільйона осіб.
Український трак з написом "Be Pride Like Ukraine"
- майже на початку колони.
Вперше до підтримки українського трака офіційно долучилось посольство України в Німеччині.
Для мене важливо приєднатися до української ЛГБТК громади в Берліні,
тому що це все про свободу.
Це універсальна цінність, яку українці сьогодні захищають.
Захищають на фронті, захищають як не урядовці, захищають як громада.
Це також про рівність.
На фронті всі рівні.
Коли ти борешся за свободу і наші хлопці, і дівчата,
і наші представники ЛГБТ-ком’юніті
- вони всі брати по зброї на фронті.
І ми всі стоїмо за Європу, за європейські цінності.
Законопроєкт про цивільні партнерства, який дозволить реєструвати одностатеві шлюби
був внесений до Верховної Ради України на початку цього року.
Це був би серйозний крок для всієї квірспільноти.
Особливо тих, хто воює на війні.
Партнерка Станіслави Аліна - військова.
Вона щойно приїхала у відпустку додому зі свого підрозділу.
Вона не приховує своєї сексуальної орієнтації від товаришів,
але каже, що реакція була неоднозначною.
Пара влаштувала імітацію весілля з друзями.
У нас є фотографії, у нас є відео з нашого перформансу,
який виглядає як церемонія.
Але ми все ще не можемо одружитися в Україні.
Важко до цього ставитися, як до особистого свята.
Ми все ще не можемо одружитися.
Вона також знає, як і всі інші квірвійськові,
що якщо її поранять або вб’ють, її партнерка
не матиме права ухвалювати рішення щодо неї.
Ми хочемо юридично захистити нашу сім'ю.
Для нас, щоб планувати взагалі майбутнє
потрібен якийсь захист від держави.
І якесь визнання від держави того, що ми є. І ми сім'я.
Ця родина бореться за майбутнє України - і своє місце в ній.